what's going on guys
spring is here which means one thing
winter is coming
that's right Game of Thrones returns for
season six this Sunday but with more
characters than ever spread out all
around Westeros Essos and all the other
OSes it's hard to keep everything
straight that's why we're here
once again to tell you everything you
need to know on the idiots guide to Game
of Thrones oh by the way there's going
to be some spoilers duh before we begin
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace
where you can build professional-looking
website regardless of your skill level
for more info check the link in the
description below
let us begin in the only place that
makes Washington DC look like a
functional seat of government King's
Landing where Papa Tywin Lannister is
being given the old game of thrones
googly-eyes after Tyrion pop a few
arrows in his ass with Lannisters
dropping like flies and the Dornish
Prince Oberyn the red Viper Martel's
brain bits still being scraped off the
tapestry Searcy is on guard and after
getting a threatening piece of snake
mail from Dorne brother Jaime sent off
on a secret mission to bring back his
niece / daughter Marcella remember that
one the Tyrion had sent away back in
season 2 I'm going to do one now
bringing outdoors out who better to tag
along with the one-handed sister then
Bronn the cell sword with a heart of
gold in that he would sell his own heart
for gold we'll get back to the road trip
in a sec but still in King's Landing
Cersei has even more threats to deal
with and first up Margaery Tyrell the
hottie queen batting her eyes who's
moved on from Joffrey to Tommen the
other other Lannister incest baby you
follow right finally one of Marjorie's
husband survives both the wedding and
the wedding day Margaery has convinced
her freshly devirginized new husband to
send his tiger mom packing back to
Casterly Rock she'll never let you out
of her sight
but wouldn't you be happier in cost you
broke
uh-uh she's having none of it in typical
restrained fashion she deals with
arrival by creating Game of Thrones
version of the Taliban the faith
militant led by the so humble it's kind
of obnoxious high Sparrow
I know shoes I gave him away to someone
who needed them more the faith goes all
letter the law on the Tyrells as Searcy
intended throwing Loras Tyrell in jail
for being gay and Margaery Tyrell in
jail for covering it up but let she who
is without brother and cousin lovin cast
the first stone
remember cousin Lancel Searcy's boy-toy
from season one well he's been born
again and he's ready to snitch on Searcy
now Searcy's thrown in jail for crimes a
cheat totally committed I am The Queen
what's King Tommen gonna do about it ah
nothing he's sweet but useless the queen
is in prison and there is nothing I can
do to gain her freedom
Searcy must take the longest walk of
shame of all time literally
Shane Shane I got a feeling now that
she's not gonna let that one slide so
good thing she ends the season in the
arms of her brand-new Franken Mountain
red Viper bad meanwhile in the North
brothel owner turned Lord of a freaking
Kingdom Littlefinger that guy is
scheming and conniving he's married off
Sansa Stark to the bastard yes Bolton of
Maul Ramsay otherwise known as holy
how'd they come up with someone worse
than Joffrey but don't worry big ol
Breanna ptarth and her new bestie
Podrick still have her back just from a
very respectful distance that you
practically need binoculars to see from
seriously they're gonna wait Annette in
all season looking for a candle I mean
leaving a lot to chance
Santa's marriage to Ramsay goes even
worse than expected but at least she
finds out that Theon didn't actually
kill her little brothers tell me that
they won your brother was brown and
wrinkled I couldn't find me that's
something right at Castle black with the
king-beyond-the-wall mance rayder's
wildling army defeated by Stannis the
baratheon Jon Snow's moping has joined
forces with Stannis's grumpiness to make
the wall an even more depressing place
as if that was even possible good thing
the red woman NOAA Sandra's there to
brighten things up by burning mance
alive to her ancient fire gone as if he
didn't even have enough to mope about
already jon has voted in a soul Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch
responsibilities now he's got to chop
off the heads of his rebellious
underlings refuse offers to abandon his
post from Stannis refuse the red woman's
fiery loins and send his best bro Sam
off to become a maester you know nothing
Jon Snow heavy is the head that wears
the curls unlike everyone else on the
show Jon is actually concerned about the
army of ice zombies about to murder
their way south he is so desperate he's
willing to work with their sworn enemies
the wildlings and he goes on a rescue
mission with tormund Giantsbane in one
of the most awesome battle scenes in
show history hardhome there's Giants
zombies skeleton kids basic mayhem Jon's
Valyrian steel sword seems to do pretty
well against the White Walkers but
unless he's got a duffel bag full of
priceless weapons it looks like the wall
and everyone's south of it are pretty
much boned we even see a little more of
the badass nights king with the
beautiful blue eyes who gives Jon
televisions most epic come at me bro
gesture of all time Jon and the
wildlings barely make it back to Castle
black with their lives intact which is
more than you could say for Stannis you
think you're having a bad day well with
his back against the wall literally and
his war to conquer Westeros in dire
straits he burns his beloved daughter
Shireen at the stake for good fortune
hey maybe next time just light a prayer
candle am i right and his wife hangs
herself but most of his troops ride off
the red woman abandons him and his
attack on Winterfell goes about as well
as a bugs attack on a bus windshield
finally out of that room Brienne deals
the killing blow to the man responsible
for the murder of her beloved Renly
Baratheon all of those seasons ago
never want to let a good tragedy go to
waste
the show has Theon and Sansa used the
failed attack on Winterfell as an excuse
to maybe sort of commit double suicide
by jumping off the city walls and just
in case you weren't bummed enough yet
Jon Snow is betrayed by his brothers for
giving the wildlings a helping hand
through the wash is he really dead is
coming back to life that the red lady is
there she does hocus-pocus what are you
doing to me Game of Thrones I can't quit
you
we're Jaime and Bronn throughout all
this they're hacking and slashing their
way through Dorne the vaguely Spanish
spice to King's Landing white bread it's
a race to rescue Jaime's daughter
Marcella and their competition is the
sand snakes newly fatherless bastard
daughters of Oberyn the red Viper
Martell sand snakes and oberyn's lover
ilaria want to murder Marcella in order
to provoke a war with the Lannisters
good thing for the world that Dorne is
ruled by Prince Doran he arrests all
these hot Headz and lets him talk out
their problems on a very special episode
of Game of Thrones I cannot disobey my
king's command she would return with you
to King's Landing and everyone lives
happily ever after right
no way Myrcella gets a poison kiss on
the way out of town dies in the arms of
her father who until recently she
thought was her uncle and with Joffrey
and Marcella gone all Jaime and Cersei
have left is Tom and sweet useless
Tommen it's almost like it's unlucky to
have sex with your brother and pop out a
bunch of illegitimate kids let us
venture across the Narrow Sea to Essos
former royal Spider Varys has smuggled
father murdering Tyrion Lannister east
to help guide Queen Daenerys Targaryen
in the finer arts of diplomacy
while Tyrion seems more interested in
mastering the art of puke and rally
but their timing is perfect because boy
does the mother of dragons have her
hands full after conquering slay city of
marine she's been forced to park two
over three dragons in the garage ever
since they developed a taste for human
flesh
now adhering to her personal code of you
break it you buy it
Danny's gonna rule this place no matter
how boring it is for us to watch and
after making everyone in the city
furious with her flip-flopping on
slavery in the fighting pits a
full-scale revolt breaks out
Tyrion makes there in time to help but
he would have showed up a lot sooner if
he hadn't been kidnapped by Lord of the
friendzone Jorah Mormont
you'd think bringing your crush a funny
dwarf would get you back in her good
graces but no still exiled and he's also
got a mean case of the uncurable
disfiguring disease greyscale for his
troubles making him just the saddest
character of all time just when the
revolution of marine goes fully out of
control her wild dragon drogon makes a
timely appearance and flies Daenerys as
far away from marine as we'd all like to
be at this point only to drop her back
off with those dots rocky what those
Klingon dudes on horses from season one
we are literally back to where we
started could we just get the mother of
dragons to Westeros this century is that
too much to ask but Danny's not the only
girl learn a thing or two in the east
there's also Arya Stark after acing how
to kill 101 she's admitted to graduate
school at the house of black and white a
religious cult slash murder dojo that
any 11-year old would be lucky to get
into she's taken under the wing of
awesome faceless assassin jock and Hegar
from season two and everything seems to
be going swimmingly until she goes rogue
and murders Meryn Trant the man who
killed her sword fighting teacher Syrio
Forel in season 1 remember he was
fighting them with a wooden sword he can
scratch one name off the list Arya oh
and scratch your eyesight too
what is with these Starks can they not
catch a break
beheaded crippled marry a psychopath
dead blind and finally huh bran who's so
important to the story right now he was
completely written out of season five
which left him somewhere in the north
learning from the three-eyed Raven in
sight that tree I'm just gonna assume
that Rickon OSHA Gendry and all the
other Forgotten characters from this
show are up there to see on Sunday brand
so there you have it the Tyrells are in
church jail Searcy's pissed off Jaime
and Bronn are on their way back with
only one living incest child left the
Lannister name Jon Snow is dead the ice
zombies are still coming the Bolton's
hold Winterfell
Tyrion Varys and Lord friendzone are
ready to ride for their queen and marine
but Daenerys is back to square one and
we are out of books the show is out run
george RR martin which admittedly is not
difficult to do but still the night is
dark and full of no more spoilers from
book readers ah see never reading a book
eventually pays off but we leave out are
you upset that we didn't mention sam
losing his v card to his girlfriend
Gilly
oh my or the sudden disappointing and
inexplicable death of sir Barristan
Selmy let us know in the comments below
I want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter
bye like wait how there's more starting
next Monday April 25th our new Game of
Thrones recap show watching Thrones
begins you'll be able to break down
every episode of Game of Thrones with
Auslan screen junkies Plus Spencer meet
Michelle Boyd special guest is gonna be
fun you don't have to wait till Monday
you can go to screen junkies calm right
now to see our season recap for all five
seasons of Game of Thrones so your watch
begins now winter is here sweating my
balls off this thing bye bye thank you
to Squarespace for sponsoring this
episode
for more information click on the link
in the description don't forget you can
catch watching thrones free right now on
screen junkies comm with our seasons 1
through 5 recaps and brand new episodes
recapping season 6 begin Monday April
25th live on screen junkies Plus will
remember all the characters names and
help you remember all the characters
desk so you can grieve all over again
Valar morghulis